Let's go next to let's go next to Tim.
From the 6 3 1.
It's been a few months since I heard from
argumentative Tim.
As we have him in our call system.
What's going on, Tim?
That's my nickname, hundred.
Yeah.
Oh, good to hear from you.
I've been following you for quite some time
with all a lot of people.
Quite some time.
And I wanted to get your take on, you know,
the current status of the roll out of opening
businesses and what your take is on the Dallas
woman that recently got arrested and sent
to jail for opening her business while they're
at the same time wanting criminals out on
the street.
I think it's very counterproductive.
I don't know anything about that story in
Dallas.
I just have not seen it or read about it.
But I'll check it out.
I mean, here's my doubt him.
My sense is that there are states that have
numbers that justify safe, socially distancing,
reopening of some elements of the economy.
We're starting to see the numbers improve
in a bunch of different states.
And I want the economy reopened as quickly
as is safely possible.
So that's fantastic.
On the other hand, I'm also seeing some states
where the cases are exploding.
Texas is an example where 10 days ago they
had about four to six hundred new cases a
day.
Now Texas has eight to twelve hundred new
cases a day.
So I have no special insight.
I'm just looking at the data and listening
to health experts.
It seems there are states that aren't yet
ready.
Well, a lot of those numbers, when it comes
to more people getting it and more people
being asymptomatic is actually good news if
you have a higher mortality rate.
We've actually broken the curve, especially
in places where I'm from New York.
I have family out there.
It seems to be kind of breaking the fever,
as it were.
It's not as bad as it once was.
Well, I think.
What's important to look at, though, is a
lot of these states have very low testing
rates.
So let me I'll give you one example and see
if this resonates with you.
In Massachusetts, we test at about three and
a half times the rate of Texas and that we
used to always have more new cases in Massachusetts
than in Texas.
That's reversed.
And for a couple of days in the last week,
Texas had more new cases than Massachusetts,
despite only testing at about 30 percent of
the level of Massachusetts.
So that's one thing I would certainly look
at.
The other is that the deaths are not based
on testing.
So when you look at the actual deaths, those
are also spiking in Texas.
So I think, you know, your point is well taken.
But when you see deaths spiking as well, that's
not about testing rates.
What we're seeing right now, I think, is a
very big rise in authoritarianism.
So the Dallas woman I described, she was actually
killed on video.
And this is all over Fox.
This is one of the biggest news stories in
the United States.
I'm not sure how you haven't seen it, but
when it comes to the judge, he was a leftist
judge that pleaded with her.
You will apologize and bend the knee on what?
I will take you to jail if you don't.
And she didn't, which I'm happy for her.
But that's the type of power grabbing we're
seeing in the United States right now.
And it's absolutely unacceptable.
And it goes against people's rights.
I would sure you agree.
You would agree as a liberal.
You know, either classical or otherwise is
going against our constitutional rights on
a huge scale.
What?
What's.
Wait, hold on.
What goes against who's constitutional right
and which right?
Being able to feed their families, people
being able to feed their families based off
of fear.
That's not backed by credible numbers.
That's not backed by facts.
We're taking stuff from the CDC where one
minute they're saying that.
Look who, by the way, is 30 percent funded
by China.
Wait a second.
No.
OK.
What's an ask?
It's not OK to wear a mask.
Tim, you also don't wear a mantle that has
got to wear a mask.
We're got to go use the wearing and don't
go.
There's a great piece here, Tim.
We've got to go.
I want to really understand what you're saying.
So which constitutional right is violated
by a stay at home?
Public health guideline?
Search, illegal search and seizure.
There's plenty of them.
Secondly, if so, here's how do stop, though.
You've got to stop him with who?
What?
What search and seizure happens when people
are told you should stay home and wear a mask
in public.
What's the search and see?
OK.
Someone's someone's at a park.
They get arrested by the police.
The woman in Idaho.
Then they search her vehicle.
Is that illegal?
You're all over the place, Tim.
We're not talking about her.
My question was, I do believe that search
and seizure are all so.
So they search your car after their property
and take her kids.
That wasn't my concern for being was of my
car and that was me.
My question was then, what about a stay at
home?
Order is in is an anti-constitutional illegal
search and seizure.
OK.
So when you don't stay at home and go to a
place like a public park where your tax dollars
pay for and then they arrest you there because
you're not safe.
Apparently is the park older widows.
Hold on.
As the park up because park rangers have authority.
Right.
Is the park open or closed?
Because if it's closed for trespassing right
now federally.
All right, Tim.
All right, my friend.
Early Tim's all over the place.
He we can't stay.
At first it was about a woman in Texas.
Then it's about constitution.
Then it's about search and seizure.
Then it's about it's a closed Idaho park.
But then he says it's it's not federal.
But you said it was Idaho.
Tim's all over the place